but anyways going back to this uh you
know a topic of you said something early
you said i don't have time to you know i
only want the best i only want the best
i only want the best okay fine
um
how do you react
when you see a ben simmons oh
i strained my back in the game yesterday
oh but the phillies still have to pay me
the 76ers still have to pay me 20
million bucks
oh you know uh
simone biles oh this is too much
pressure you guys don't know how much
pressure it is i know i'm sure there's a
lot of pressure from everybody oh you
know uh naomi osaka somebody said you
suck can i get the mic and say something
i thought that was very weird to have
something like that happen you know how
do you handle you know everything that
these kids are going through and now
they're becoming adults with social
media with all of that
yet
you
said the doctor lower
however you print the layer however you
pronounce his name he wrote those
engagements something about engagement
full engagement
everything's about mental toughness
everything's about emotional toughness
everything's about that everything how
do you manage what these kids and
athletes are saying nowadays it's too
much anxiety for me to play sports how
do you manage that yeah well first off
one of the things i i try to teach
everybody having the ability to forget
is more important than remember probably
not just sports but life yeah i mean
some people are still mad about stuff 20
years later and that's a skill you got
to have the ability to flip things in
your mind and take a negative and turn
it into a positive and it's hard because
everything's black and white like you
said with social media everybody is more
sensitive to all this stuff but at the
end of the day with simmons and biles
and
naomi since i don't really
know them and how they're wired i'm just
looking from the outside you know it's
ironic because
it's easy maybe to take that approach
because they're still all making a lot
of money you know soccer is getting 50
million dollars a year
you know
simmons is making all this money same
with biles so
i don't really know them but looking
from the outside it's it's a bad look
for anybody you gotta toughen up you
know that's what people are gonna say
but i don't really like to comment on
that because i don't know them if you
ask me about someone else and i knew
them i could tell you exactly what the
temperature was and why that is going on
well let me ask you this you're when you
uh uh coach the the folks that you coach
okay capriati all the names that you
just said right there you coached
radical those guys
uh how did how would you have handled it
if one of them or maybe did you ever
have a player that came up that
constantly was like mental and emotional
anxiety all of that and you just
eventually said look the pros just name
i may not be for you you know you may
want to go to a different job because
this comes with a lot of pressure how
did you handle that when that came up
when you were coaching them well that
does come up in the juniors because
people get nervous i've never had
anybody like at the mountaintop say that
like some of these people that you've
discussed i mean that's a whole that's a
whole different deal when they've had
all that success and money and they've
went through the process and they've
learned how to win and lose and they've
won grand slams it's a little different
but we don't know what's going on in
their personal life there could be just
a lot of other stuff that's going on so
once again i gotta i would talk to them
okay that this comes with the territory
if you want to be great this is what
it's all about you know having the
ability to
forget you you it's a skill okay if
you're going to react to everything
you might nibble near the top you ain't
going to stay there because greatness
can stay there because they're
consistent mentally so unless i knew
exactly um a perfect example is rotting
you know he was so
mentally strong i knew his forehand was
going to be nuclear and the serve that i
helped him achieve was going to be super
sonic but he was just a dog you know he
was bulletproof i loved watching him
playing i interviewed him five six years
ago oh erotically yeah i had radical
valuetainment
guy
man he was exciting to watch yeah you
know he had limitation but at the end of
the day he had the best quote of
everything when he started making all
this money he goes listen
everything else around me has changed
but it's still me and you and the court
i'm going to kick your butt
i gotta actually
i don't want to say push back on you but
i gotta follow up yeah i know you said
you you know you don't really work or
you're kind of from a distance with the
ben simmons of the world and the simone
biles but naomi osaka is a tennis player
a female tennis player you've coached
dozens if not hundreds of female tennis
players you coach serena and venus
williams hello
she made her name beating serena i
believe right and she cried and she won
you know i don't remember what
tournament it was but that's u.s open
she was a big winner yeah and then now
this past year she's had her issues
i mean if you can kind of get into the
mind of her because i believe you
probably do know her better than
any other you know
under the players that we mentioned
but if you were her coach or if you were
advising the coach what specific things
would you do because you do have
experience with this exact type of
person yeah no you know like i said
there has to be a lot of stuff
off the court because her life has
changed
when you go from maybe having not a lot
to be the richest female athlete
on the planet
okay and you know she's
in japan she's this iconic so
either in or out i i to me i'm black and
white about this stuff you you got to be
so mentally strong if you're going to be
in you're in if you're out you're out
you you can't be half in and you can
kind of see that in her performance
she's
not all there because if you don't want
to die
to win every point you're going to lose
against better players i mean that's
what people don't see they might say oh
my kid has a better server forehand they
don't know what's under the hood and her
mental toughness was her strength and
now that she's
being sensitive and stuff like that i
would have a very different conversation
uh with her i don't even know if i'd
want to coach her
if a player responded like that unless i
had more information then i'd have a
little better feel let me ask the
question a different way because i know
what you're you're you're you're walking
you know you're in the business so you
can't really give the answer on a mic
that you you know
anyway so i understand i respect that
but let me ask a question a different
way
when you were coaching in the 80s 90s
you've you've coached in five different
decades no am i saying it correctly or
six to four decades five different
decades right yep okay so
how much was this the topic of
discussion in the 80s 90s 2000
amazing question
never
okay that's the question that's what
you're saying no that's never a question
no never yeah never once you're saying
you're saying mental toughness or what
anxiety tough depression i'm like oh my
god i can't handle this no no it's it's
because it's a real thing these days
no no no no no no no they're making it a
real yeah
no it's it's the social media it's
entitlement kids are brought up
different you know there's you know kids
are a little more spoiled you know
things are easier you know it's it's
it's just different even physical
fitness different kids got in shape by
just running around outside playing tag
now you got trainer it's a it's a
different world and it's create uh
created a lot of marshmallows mentally
you know what i'm saying and so but
that's that's the question right there
this never ever came up to the point
where you even kind of felt it let alone
would express it like that i mean so
that means it's very deep so how can
kids be kids be mentally tougher it
sounds like you agree with exactly what
pat where pat was going i agree exactly
how do you keep your kids your coaching
these days let me ask you a different
question let me ask a different question
let me ask a different question
you're the expert we're just amateurs
here we're not in the world we're in a
completely different world we're in okay
how much of
this
is a
problem
that was non-existent that's been
created purely out of the
you know out of the imagination of you
know how they say
all these new uh uh for what's what's
the uh
phobics that we have afraid of this
afraid of that afraid of this or
whatever and then you need these new
medicines you need this new this new
this big pharma is making all this money
based on different fears that they're
making and all these medicines that
people are taking is based on all these
phobias that was created by these uh
scientists who represent these big
pharma again these are stories we've all
read about how much of it is just
fabricated that's got these kids
believing i really have this issue
yeah a lot of it okay you know what i
mean because it's like everybody wants a
quick fix okay uh to
to get anywhere you got to take the
stairs not the escalator you know what i
mean everybody wants a quick fix on
everything yeah um but no you're you're
right this this never existed but i need
to dive in about the family component
a lot of this also
is
the mom and dad okay because
not that they have total control over it
but they are raising kids
they are raising kids some just throw
them out there and let them grow like
grass other water it and fertilize it
yeah you know so the parents you know
they want their kid to be rough and
tough and you know be competitive and
take a punch and then they go the ball
and buy them a gucci bag so you know
it's just a bizarre
thing
that it's a lot of it is
the parent you know and i'll go back to
where i started you know this interview
richard
richard williams what i saw
at nine and ten okay which other people
didn't it wasn't on the outside outside
was a train wreck sorry venus serena it
was a trade by where he told him that it
was a train wreck on the outside but on
the inside
i never saw it so that box was checked
and a few others because i knew
i knew
that's the wild card you don't know how
people are gonna freak out under
pressure a quarterback when some guy
wants to knock him out yeah you know
when the game's on you don't know that
and i saw
they the minute i changed the game
to like competitive
it it kind of freaked me out and i've
never been freaked out about anything so
but that was done
at a young age and that's why why
richard williams was just saying all
this insanity
uh because he saw the same thing but it
took someone
that had that eye because on the outside
you can't see it if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you